first off eggs sugar butter and when I
say way out of the ingredients it does
literally mean way out to the final gram
175 now 175 grams of sugar that's 350
grams in total cream the butter and the
sugar let's get a delicious light sponge
start carefully on slow speed only speed
up as the butter and sugar really start
to cream together keep that already nice
to lightly to see how it's changed color
so important beginning eggs in the
minute whisk adding one egg at a time
stops the mix from separating the second
oh yeah
both women
that's what we're looking for a really
nice sort of light airy ad texture now
go flavour the sponge little teaspoon of
vanilla extract
like perfumes the mix 1 teaspoon of
baking powder
that gives lightness 175 grams of flour
and we have a sieve it a to get rid of
any lumps and B to keep it really nice
and fine 175 what I'm gonna beat that
out
we're just gonna lightly fold that in
now what I'm looking for is a really
nice loose dough that's looking a little
bit too firm so just a little splash of
milk a couple of tablespoons that
relaxes the mixture down helps to create
that nice almost dropping consistency so
on yeah starting to drop take a non
stick loose bottom caked in grease with
butter then coated with flour to avoid
the sponge sticking just give that a
little shake make sure you get it all
over in
now just get the back of the spatula
make sure you got no Peaks on my sponge
to make sure the sponge base nice and
evenly tap the tin a few times to knock
out any air pockets that might have
formed in the mixture now into the oven
bake for 30 to 35 minutes at 180 degrees
as that's cooking prepare a ginger cream
for the center 300 mil of cream give
that nice whisk whisking cream by hand
gives you so much milk control and it's
so easy to over whipped cream or on that
nice light ginger cream in the center I
don't it grainy nothing worse when cream
starts separate now let's get into that
3/4 stage a little stiff peaks stop that
for two minutes
fresh ginger now get a really nice large
slice of ginger it smells incredible
it's so fragrant Ginger's like sort of
peeling a potato just take it all those
little dark spots
now get your grater then got a grater
you can chop the ginger really finely
I've gotten almost like a puree of
ginger going through but the juice as
well take your knife just spreadable
that will taste
it's fragrant it's not sweet it's got a
really nice taste set that in the fridge
[Music]
smells incredible run a knife around the
outside to ensure the cake doesn't stick
to the tin before turning it out now get
your hands under push up and bow while
your cake cools under like a really nice
sweet chocolate coating pour 300 mils of
double cream into a saucepan add two
tablespoons of golden syrup to make the
top nice and glossy
then whisk chop this up really thinly so
as it melts quickly 50 grams of butter
that's gonna give the chocolate a really
nice shine all your cream mix it in give
that a really good stir there's a
chocolate the butter melts it thickens
because Shia is so nice to finish it
with something sweet on top
topping done time to build your sponge
cake look at the halfway mark there and
just gently slice and really take your
time all the way through lift
mmm-hmm delicious a nice big dollop in
the middle don't be stingy
let me tight with a cream another dollop
and top spread that very carefully lift
the lid and just sit that on top that's
why I start off with a little extra
cream in there someone squash you down
the cream just pushes it out to the side
I'm not finished
poor the luxurious chocolate topping
over the sponge be generous and make
sure the cake is coated thoroughly diva
a gorgeous finish to the bottom the
ladle and spread or one more wha there
are no when to say stop and something
looks that delicious iced white dive in
there
[Music]
whilst the prof infuses so cool rice
noodles in boiling water for 10 minutes
just enough time to fry your fritters
now think what's going on the tartness
the heat the caramel the color on the
ribs is amazing